Two things before we get started today.
One,
they're all weird pronunciations in this one.
I'm looking them up when I can.
I have a laptop right here.
Sometimes it doesn't exist.
Sometimes they're just owned the pronunciations available.
I'm doing my best,
but have a good.
I mean the comments if you want.
Second thing,
this video is brought to you by squarespace.
Whether you need a domain,
website or online store,
make it with squarespace.
Check out squarespace.com for a free trial.
Find the link below.
All right,
so for three years and eight months,
Pol Pot ruled over Cambodia with an iron fist.
The legacy that he left his horrific millions of families were torn apart.
Hundreds of thousands were terribly tortured and one point 7 million of his own
people will put to death.
So how did it end this way?
On this week's biographics,
we attempt to see.
Colin says,
as we delve into the life of Pol Pot,
the man who the world would come to know was polled.
Part was born Sar on January the 25th,
19,
25 in the small village of praxis in Cambodia is was a peasant family and from
an early age he found himself working long hours in the rice fields.
The selloff Klan were better off than many being landowners who worked that own
rice fields,
saw his father,
owns nine hashtags and would employ local workers at harvest time.
His mother saw him was a devoutly religious woman who brought up her children as
Theravada Buddhists.
Saul was the second to youngest of nine children,
however,
three of them died early according to his brother and A.
Saul was a considerate,
kind and hard working child.
During the day,
he and his brothers would work in the fields,
then play in the rivers and on the outskirts of the jungle.
In the evening,
they would gather around and open,
fire and sing the teachings and histories of a local religious leader.
For the vast majority of Railroad Cambodians,
life revolved around the rice fields in the village.
If you've ever traveled to beyond the borders of their birthplace,
however,
wanted his sons to experience more from life.
So when he was six,
Sar and his older brother was sent to the Cambodian capital,
Phnom Penh loft had a cousin by the name of me who was employed as a consort to
the king of Cambodia,
and the boys were sent to live with him,
no longer considered as peasants sergeant,
his brother well now among the privileged.
As such,
they were educated by the French.
Colonial rule is in a school where the teaching was done in the French language,
saw studied French literature and history,
filling his head with the events of the 1789 French revolution and the reign of
terror that followed under the orchestration of Maximilian Robespierre.
Former school names rather than saw was there quiet,
introspective young man who kept his thoughts to himself.
He was an average student at best apparently being held back two years.
Most of his classmates were the children of French officials or Catholic
Vietnamese.
Cambodia was officially a monarchy,
but the king,
he ruled in name only with the real power lying with the French colonial
governments.
At this time,
the French were tied up in a bit of a struggle to hold onto their power in
neighboring Vietnam bad.
The Communist army under Ho Ci Minh was leading the struggle for independence,
the Vietnamese revolutionaries that started to train small groups of Cambodians
and infuse them with the desire for independence from this European rule.
This was a movement that was spreading throughout all of India,
China at this time,
at the age of 28,
so traveled with some friends on a pilgrimage to the famous temples at Angkor
Wat.
This site was the rallying point for Cambodian nationalistic pride.
The trip left a lasting impression on the young men in 1970,
70 status.
If our people could build ankle wash,
they could do anything we must revive on national soul and pride in order to
defend the nation bills the country well then preserve it forever.
The trip mocks the awakening of saws,
political consciousness,
and his drawing for independence.
In 1947,
he passed the exams and gained entrance into the Cecil was author secondary
college and Phnom Penh,
but the following year he failed the entry exam into the upper classes and he
had to leave the school with his academic career seemingly at a standstill.
He began to study carpentry.
Then in 1949,
do you want a scholarship to study at an elite engineering school in Paris?
For the first few months,
he indulged in the excesses that Parisians social life had to offer.
This thing's changed when he came into contact with some fellow Cambodian,
so you had views that builds upon the spark of nationalist pride that had been
ignited at Angkor Wat.
The group that began meeting at size apartments and discussions can lead to the
formation of two groups,
one who advocated working peacefully towards independence from the French and
the other who were in favor of armed resistance.
From the very start saw was in the latter camp.
He endures likeminded friends.
They pointed to other countries around the world were armed overthrow was
working,
and they noticed they all had one thing in common.
The rebels were all communists.
There was a vibrant communist movements in Paris at the time and sirens.
Those of his group he worked for armed rebellion,
began attending meetings,
saw again studying the teachings of Karl Marx,
but found them difficult to understand.
However,
he readily cottoned onto the writings of Joseph Stalin and became a lifelong
advocate of Stalinism with its emphasis on rapid industrialization,
totalitarian governments,
and the cult of personality.
In 1951,
he joined the Communist Party and by the time that he returned to Cambodia in
1953,
he had committed himself to the cause of the Cambodian revolution once back on
Cambodians soil sir journey north to join up with Cambodian forces who had
attached themselves to the Vietnamese communists and that fight for independence
from the French.
He now lived in the jungle is a perspective guerilla fighter,
but first he amped to do an apprenticeship.
For the first few months,
his duties consisted of maintaining the group's vegetable patch paydays recalled
most everyone that was Vietnamese that were very few Cambodians for a long time,
there was nothing for me to do.
After awhile they let me work in the kitchen,
but really the Cambodians were there in name only.
Victory was achieved by Vietnamese communists in 1953 following the French
disaster at the battle of DNB and food.
The French pulled out of not just Vietnam,
but Cambodia also.
However,
the new nationalists,
Cambodian government who has had it not by a communist,
probably the King Norodom Sihanouk still the top third of Cambodia,
was under the control of Viet Minh,
so Erin's other local communist soldier,
the Viet Minh to continue pushing south until the entire country was communist.
But the leadership of the Viet Minh resisted.
This surgeon's.
A truce was arranged with the king,
so now resend to Phnom Penh where he continued to work for the political
undergrounds.
His Day job was as a school teacher where he taught history by noise,
however,
he worked to establish contacts with every strata of society,
from intellectuals to peasants in order to garner support for the coming
communist revolution around this time,
so at the man who would become his closest political associates and second in
command,
nuon chat,
chat later recalled that Sir had an innate ability to charm people and bring
them into the party.
Having the ability to explain things in a way that simple people were able to
understand,
so also met up with a revolutionary students who he had worked with in Paris by
the name of King Van Zach.
Together.
They worked on plans for the country's first free and open political elections,
so I went to vans,
Zach's house for breakfast every morning to work on their party's manifesto.
However,
that work did not come to fruition.
King Sihanouk because renounced his throat and formed his own political party,
the satin chrome.
He threw his hat into the 1955 general election and one becoming Cambodia's.
New Prime Minister Nuke had achieved this victory,
though by throwing his political rivals into prison for sub,
the Shaman action marks the end of any hopes he may have had for a democratic
means to bring about change in his country.
He confirmed his commitment to violence overthrow wins through himself towards
working toward that goal in July of 1956.
So I married a fellow Communist Party member by the name of q panare likes.
She had been educated in France and was equally committed to the revolution
recourse.
They soon became the power couple of the underground communist movements.
Life was increasingly dangerous for the communists under the rule of CNN.
He had outlawed the Communist Party and it's given them a new name,
the kind of of rouge,
the pace of imprisonments killings and general Tara was stabbed top as the prime
minister to stamp out any and all opposition to his rule.
The Communist Party secretary,
a close friend of so was taken to the outskirts of Phnom Penh and killed his
during this climate of fear.
That's a accepted the leadership of the Climber Rouge.
It was constantly followed by the police who knew who he was,
but not his position in the party.
By 1960,
three things had gotten too hot for Sarah in the capital city and d left to
dwell in the jungle in the north.
Yeah.
He was taken in by the Viet Minh who had set up camps on the Vietnam Cambodia
border.
They were now focused on a new enemy within their country.
That's of course the United States from that Cambodian basis.
They would regularly traveling to Vietnam to make lightening strikes before
retreating back over the border in response to the American strawbs,
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs in north Cambodia and and attempts to
kill the Viet Minh and the process they killed.
Over the course of the war,
nearly $150,000 Cambodians,
the American bombing,
have the effect of drawing more and more people to the [inaudible].
Soon said no longer had to rely only on the Viet Minh.
He now had his own gorilla camps stretched out along the border and he himself,
he had transformed himself in the mold of his hero,
Joseph Stalin.
He was the unquestioned party leader and he now went by the name Paul Pot.
He lives apart from the rank and file of his army and only allowed a select few
the privilege of having an audience with him.
Paul believed that the lifeblood of his revolutionary forces would come from the
peasantry,
but he also believed that they needed to be molded so their soul allegiance was
to the party.
New recruits would undergo an intense period of initiation where they would be
locked in a cell until they were proven to be obedient.
Pole instituted as a rigid disciplinary structure which included group meetings
where members have to confess their weaknesses and seek forgiveness.
In 1970,
prime minister can newquist overthrown by a military dictatorship.
He escape to the north and sought to establish an alliance with this format
enemy,
the kind of bolstered by the supporters of CNU.
The Canberra region numbers rose by 64,000.
By the spring of 1964,
many of them went.
Now,
armed with Chinese supplied rifles,
pole vault saw me of gradually filtered down from the border area and now
controlled two thirds of Cambodia.
By December of 1974 pole felt in a strong enough position to make an assault on
the capital,
became a revision cycle,
Phnom Penh,
and began to close in those you could flood.
The city is the streets became more zones.
Within five days,
the military government was overpowered and the revolution was ifn.
April the 17th,
1975 was day zero and the life of a new Cambodia,
Cambodia was now called Campo Chair and it was under the control of it's stolen
and this leader Pol Pot.
Now,
just before we get into the really,
really dark part of this video,
Paul Potts reign of terror.
I do want to thank today's sponsor.
I know ads in the middle of these videos are a little bit disruptive,
but these sorts of videos I think they're important to make and they would be
impossible.
Our sponsors.
So I really do hope in exchange for this long video about the life of Pol Pot.
You won't mind a quick word from the fantastic squarespace if you've got an
important message to share,
you can do it with squarespace or maybe you're like me and you need a place on
the web for people to find you,
or maybe you're starting a new business and you need to set up a website for an
online presence or a store.
Well,
you should do all of that with squarespace and with squarespace.
It all starts with a stunning template.
They really are super good looking,
or if you hate their beautiful templates,
I promise your won't.
You can start from scratch and make it rain.
Squarespace.
Make it all super easy to make something that looks amazing.
Furthermore,
you can easily move over an existing domain and if you've hosted websites
anywhere else,
just move over to squarespace.
It's easy to do and then everything after that point is just a lot easier.
With squarespace,
there's no patches,
there's no updates,
there's no tech crap that you have to deal with all the time.
No one likes any of that.
Further,
squarespace does have 24 slash seven support before making this out.
I went on and I tried it to see if I could reach someone just randomly and
absolutely curd solid support.
It just works.
Look whatever you need a website for whether it's for yourself or a business.
Squarespace is the place to do it.
Had to squarespace.com for a free trial and when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash buyer graphics,
and you'll get 10 percent off your first purchase of a website or domain.
Thanks again to squarespace for sponsoring.
Check them out through the link below and now let's get back to the misery that
is Pol Pot.
The people who have been on Penn,
they enthusiastically welcomes the climate rouge,
but the smiles tend to alarm at the ruthlessness of Poles.
Men,
they shot any military forces on site.
Then Paul ordered a massive evacuation of the capital.
The reason given was that the Americans were about to bomb Phnom Penh.
Guy Maria soldiers went into the city forcing people out of hospitals in their
homes.
Many died in the streets in the melee that followed.
The reality was that there was no threat of an American outrage.
Pol Pot simply wanted to get the people now so the way so that he could
concentrate on rebuilding his new society.
He told his aides that they must use cutting edge violence in order to build a
socialist system from the ground up.
The 2 million people who were forced out of Phnom Penh has a pass through these
checkpoints on the outskirts of the city that they were assigned to districts
for reeducation as field laborers,
the policy of equality with strictly enforced with any possessions that set city
folk apart from the peasantry being taken off them,
Kangaroos,
soldiers went through the now deserted capital and destroyed any of the
trappings of modern civilization that they could find.
Any people who were found to be hiding were taken into the street and shot under
Pol Pot regime.
Communist to quality meant that everyone wants to be a peasant.
As a result of all of the modern advances of the last 100 years.
They were rejected and even though former city dwellers and peasants were now
working in the field side by side,
that kind of rear driver see us held a special hatred for the form of urbanites
who are considered to be capitalists.
They were given only half of the food rations of the peasants.
The equality policy included children to live with [inaudible] teachers from the
age of seven onwards.
Private thoughts and feelings were considered to be evil with uniformity,
the only acceptable way of life the state who would choose which people got
married and anyone who was suspected of falling in love outside of this
arrangements have beaten to death and public.
The regime outlawed any form of entertainment including sports with former
sports fields and basketball courts being planted as rice fields.
The feeling of terror that had been generated reached into the Asher lawns of
power with members of Paul's governments.
Iga.
It's approved that they too were peasants and they worked in the fields.
As a result,
there was no real governance.
Poland's did use it,
a rice harvesting quota on the people,
which was three tons of unhosted rice per hectare,
but less than a third of this was actually being produced.
Meanwhile,
the people were suffering physically.
Disease was rife,
and millions suffered from malnutrition.
Hundreds of people were dying every single day.
Paul blames the lack of success of his great vision on infiltrators and enemies
of the party.
He devised a great purge to weed out those nonconformists estate secrets.
Interrogations and do is set it up so you in prison and torture.
Those were expected of being traitors.
The families of those arrested would also be taken to the prison and tortured.
If a child was too young to be interrogated,
it would be taken away and simply killed immediately.
Any adults that you survived,
that torture were taken out to the killing fields and beaten to death of the
14,000 prisoners you pass through the gates of the main interrogation center in
Phnom Penh.
Only seven survived.
Many of those killed were loyal supporters who were falsely accused of treason.
Paul Potts had succeeded in imposing his ruthless iron fisted control within the
borders of Cambodia,
but there was a new threat to his regime just over the border.
The Vietnamese is having seen off the Americans now turn their attention on
Cambodia.
A border dispute threatened to bring these two countries to war as the tensions
were rising.
Paulo did his latest purge right on the border zone.
He suspected his defensive forces in that area of colluding with the Vietnamese
after being viciously interrogated more than 100,000 soldiers and party
officials along with their wives and that children were executed as a result of
this wholesale massacre of his own defense forces.
Paul left is eastern border with Vietnam open to invasion and that invasion came
on Christmas Day.
Nineteen 78,
taking just 13 days for the capital of Phnom Penh to fall.
Pol Pot managed to slip away and escape into the jungle,
but at least his three and a half year reign of terror was over.
In total it'd cost the lives of nearly 2 million people.
The caiman ridge may have been over,
but the party persisted for nearly 20 years at retina and continued to wage
guerrilla warfare from its jungle basis.
Ballpark,
set up a base near the Thai border and rebuilt his military force with the aid
of the Chinese and Thai governments.
Meanwhile,
the Vietnamese that installed a new government made up of kind of rear
supporters who had escaped polls pageants
from his base in the northern part of the country.
Paul gave occasional interviews to reporters in which he would invariably accuse
those who opposed him of being traitors.
In 1985,
it was announced that he was retiring from the leadership of the kind of rouge.
Shortly thereafter,
the enemy's clamps down on the climate region moving into their strongholds and
decimating that basis.
Paul managed to escape into Thailand's where he remained for the next few years.
In 1988,
he went to China to undergo treatment for cancer.
The enemy's withdrew from Cambodia.
In 1988 prompting polls or a from Thailand.
For the next eight years,
the Caiman Rouge ran guerrilla operations against government forces.
In 1996,
the government began engaging in peace negotiations with individual kind of
leaders,
leading many of them to effect away from the organization.
Meanwhile,
Paul had suffered a stroke and was paralyzed on the left side of his body,
but this didn't stop him from handing out death sentences.
When he heard that his longtime righthand man,
I'm was negotiating with the government,
the audit,
his arrest and execution around this time that they've been members of Paul's
family were also killed.
Though it is unclear whether he ordered those killings.
On June the 19th,
19,
97 pole was arrested by the head of the military who had had enough of his
murderous ways.
A show trial was conducted for the ordering of the execution of transcendence.
Pole was confined to house arrest for the rest of his life
and it's finally,
as Paul had become an avid listener to the voice of America radio show on the
night of April the 17th,
1998.
He was surprised to hear that the [inaudible] should agree to handover to an
international tribunal for crimes against humanity.
Later that night,
he died in bed.
Paul Paul's body was requested by the Cambodian government for inspection,
however,
he was cremated and his followers before the government could get their hands on
it.
This is that.
Be Able to speculate that he actually committed suicide rather than being handed
over to the court.
As a result,
neither he nor anyone else has ever faced justice for the horror of Cambodian
killing fields.
So I'm not going to ask whether you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it informative and maybe brought this part of history to
life for you.
If you did like it,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell.
If you do want to hear about all videos,
just sitting subscribed doesn't do what it used to on Youtube,
so do hit that,
that as well as you do.
Find out when we put out new videos and if you're looking for something else to
watch right now,
why not check out some of the bio's link?
Do on the screen now and as always,
thank you for watching.